right we are going to bring you the
latest uh government figures on covert
19 cases uh the uk has reported a record
number of daily covert 19 cases today
for the latest 24-hour period in fact
it's the highest daily total recorded
since this pandemic began the figure is
78
610
new cases um that's compared with 59
610 a day
earlier the uk has reported 165
new deaths
from covert 19.
that's compared with 150 a day earlier
we've also got some separate data
on omicron cases
today 4
671 additional confirmed cases of the
new variant have been reported across
the uk
uh the confirmed number of omicron cases
in the uk now totals 10
and 17.
let's bring in our science correspondent
uh thomas more to react to this um
thomas this feeds into what we were
talking about earlier just the sheer
rate of infection at the moment the uk
recording its highest daily total um of
covert cases since this pandemic began
yes and it's probably two pandemics
which are happening at the same time a
delta is still spreading rapidly through
children and in unvaccinated people but
on top of that you've now got omicron
which is really racing through large
sectors of the population and that's why
i've seen a big rise in daily cases
there i think it's about 10 000 more
than the previous record is an
extraordinary rapid rise of omicron
which is going to drive those numbers
even higher as we close out the year
and uh dr harris the head of the uh the
health security agencies she was saying
earlier on to mps that cases are
doubling now every 1.9 days it is
absolutely extraordinary and we've got
more detail today on where the hot spots
are for for this so first of all um
there are i should say five additional
suspected cases of omicron in hospital
that's on top of the 10 confirmed cases
we know about and i say suspected
because they're using pcr tests now to
distinguish between omicron and uh and
delta it doesn't confirm the case but
it's very very likely to be omicron when
it does come back uh with a particular
uh genetic um uh tracing uh so looking
at that you you can see um one if we
look at the hotspots around the country
if you look at those but that bar chart
you can see that london's got about 51.8
percent of cases covered cases are now
due to omicron so omicron is already
dominant in the capital but not far
behind you've got east of england the
south east of england and the north west
they're all there between 20 and 26
percent of cases are due to omicron at
the moment and if if you that those are
for specimens taken just within the last
few days and then if we move on and take
a look at the growth curves and you can
see how rapidly these omicron cases are
rising uh with london particularly
they're going up very quickly and indeed
just uh it's gone up in the last five
days in london from around 10 percent of
all covered cases uh to 51 percent
quite an extraordinary rise and then if
you look back at those other three
regions of england that i mentioned you
can see they too are rising uh quite
quickly and if they do follow the same
growth curve of london you can expect
omicron to become a dominant strain
there too in just a very short period of
time probably three or four days
thomas thank you thomas more with the
update there on those covered 19 figures